hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video as
promised guys i would like to make a big
update on gme let's get into it
[Music]
all right so let's maybe take as usual
guys very quickly a step back
and let's see what is happening here so
i'm using elliott wave theory that i'm
trying to apply to this stock so i know
what you guys are going to tell me that
this was a squeeze and that eliot wave
theory is not applying junior squeeze
fair enough but it's not a squeeze
anymore for the past few months it is
just a big cap that is moving with a
high volatility where emotions are
involved and that is for this reason
following fibonacci and eliot wave
theory so we had here one first move up
so one two three we've almost complete
this huge force corrective wave that
actually hap started in gen 21 because
here we didn't make a new high in june
as we did for amc so this correction is
much longer which suggests that maybe
the fifth wave is gonna be uh stronger
too so now let's analyze this correction
we did that already a few times but let
me quickly here do it with you again so
uh what i was seeing is an abc with the
c wave that is coming here guys okay so
abc and
here i think that this is the beginning
of the fifth wave but it's only going to
be confirmed once we break this huge
trend line so this is the signal uh we
are all waiting for and this is at 260
roughly this level is going down so i
was saying 280 one month ago now it's
260 and in one month it's going to be
240 all right this level is going down
which is good which makes uh a very nice
entry level that is coming a lower every
day so we like entry levels going lower
so here now if we try to analyze what is
happening in this potential fifth wave
that has started let me go on the first
time frame
and
we now gonna analyze the move started in
august all right
so it's quite clear to me that this was
a one two three four five all right here
the fifth wave i wish it could go to the
270 level at that time
so that we go at least test it once and
then maybe we do a cap and handle or
something like this uh a kind of
reversal pattern but here we got uh
stopped around 230 but it's still a one
two three four five then we had this uh
sharp correction in forming so let me go
to our little frame here
forming an abc a b c
it's valid and so here what i'm not 100
sure off
is
is this abc actually complete or not i
mean is it the bottom of the second wave
and we have started the third
or would we have maybe a
longer correction once again not
necessarily deeper just like i'm saying
on amc
i think we're gonna correct one more
week i'm gonna do a video on amc
tomorrow guys but
nothing much happened since the the last
update i gave you two or three days ago
so you can go and check it out but i
will make a new one tomorrow anyways so
this is the question we are having but
what we can say right now
so let me get rid of this abc for now
because it's quite unclear to me what we
having right now is to me still a
bullish development as you can see we
make higher lows and higher highs so i'm
not sure when this third wave is
actually going to be complete but i
would say maybe end of september so this
would be interesting to see where we are
at the at the end of the month if we
break 260 it would be very good as in
terms of support uh i have here
190 that hold pretty well here you can
see we have it's the breakout level that
was here as well guys okay whenever you
have a trend line usually so here i have
the trendline that's connecting the
highs here and here in the move down
it's usually retested at least once and
here we can see we get down immediately
we went above and since then it is
support so for me this is our strong
support you also have the 200 a day
moving average so the hourly 200 period
moving average coming here so it might
as act as support as well if we go down
so for now my view i'm kind of neutral
on the short term of course i'm bullish
on the long term but for the short term
i need to see more price action
i would say that if we break 230 on the
upside this would confirm that wave 2 is
complete
and this would open the way to the 260
70 resistance level and on the downside
i think that all this area is a very
good area to accumulate more positions
so i'm not saying we're going to go
there but if we do i think it's a very
nice level to get in
now let's have a look quickly at the
synthetic short interest because you
know guys that this is very important
this is what is creating the upside
gamma
okay so what do we have here we were at
22 last time oh yeah because now the
september expiry
is gone
hey
so
what maturity can we add
24 maybe
ah
okay i have something
okay and maybe
uh so 21 to maybe 31 here
and here 24.
okay
and
yes to the 1st of september doesn't
exist right
so it's not working since the 1st of
october
up
october 1st
okay
so here we are guys so as we can see the
all the option uh interest has not been
rolled from september to the uh next
maturities because we're at 21 maximum
synthetic short we are now only at 16.
so let's see if this is rebuilding so
there is of course a lot of gamma
because we can go from four percent of
synthetic short interest to 16 so we
have here 11
uh roughly even 12 of upside gamma which
is good the regular shot is stable at 10
percent so nothing much here to say
about the option market let's see once
again this huge strike here is it
growing
uh so we are right now at 2.5 million
shares guys equivalent so yeah this is
uh the biggest open interest strike that
we have and this is the reason why uh of
course this is so explosive on the
upside if we start moving above 250 but
above 300 this is gonna start to create
a lot of troubles to market makers so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys